amazon is trying to figure out what to
do with stargate when the mgm sale
finally goes through hopefully by summer
2022.
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv movie
channel
[Music]
so if you're returning to the channel
and you are a regular sidetracker you'll
know that i've talked about stargate a
lot because i've been in contact with a
couple of people that work with mgm on
the creative side and they've been
giving me drip feeding me a few little
bits of information
so i have tried to tie them down to give
me a really good idea of what is
actually on the drawing board at the
moment
the people i'm talking to are
speculating to a point they know what
conversations are going on but none of
this is decided until the mgm amazon
sale is finalized none of this will be
decided
they're trying to prepare for the day
the mgm sale does become finalized and
they can crack on they don't want to
start from the beginning if there's
anything they can do to prepare they're
doing that now and to do that they've
basically drawn up three plans plan a is
the preferred option
if the mgm sale is finalized within the
next couple of months my source is
actually saying potentially march or
april this could be done
then they will begin full swing into
producing a movie that movie will
hopefully be hitting our screens before
winter of 2023.
now at the moment there's no script for
that movie but there is apparently a
basic storyline and they do have an idea
who they want to write produce and
direct there is some
ideas potentially that the team that
produce the tomorrow war might actually
be involved that project
now
following that quickly there will be a
television series our television series
will start within a couple of weeks of
the movie premiering the idea being
basically that the film will create a
lot more hype in a series alone and will
really kick start the whole project with
a big bang
now the tv series they're producing
ideally they want brad wright to be
involved in that but amazon has
questions about the project that he's
already penciled out we know that brad
writer has an idea for how he wants one
series to go ahead he was
asked by mgm to produce a series and
he's done that he's also written a
pilot episode
amazon apparently executives want that
to be a bit bigger and they also want to
tie in the television series into the
movie and obviously the movie hasn't
actually been written yet so
that will need some reworking of the
series
apparently amazon also wanted the movie
and the tv series to become tied in with
the game stargate timekeepers they want
all of these projects to influence each
other and come together
now there is also another piece of
information i've been told about that
project potentially with brad right but
that's for another video
plan b
if the sale of mgm drags on much longer
beyond the summer potentially then
amazon are likely to change their plan
they want stargate on our screens as
early as possible the preferred option
is for a movie then a series but
a movie takes 18 months to produce a tv
series could be go from being greenlit
to honor screens within six months
so
if that is delayed further they will
start with the tv series again preferred
option is to go with brad wright who
will have to potentially rework and
rewrite what he's already prepared and
come up with something a little bit new
but they are willing to go with other
people if that doesn't work out
and then produce a movie to follow it
now this is basically just going to mean
reworking the stories a little bit so
that they work together that way
but this way they can still get stargate
in one way or another on our screens by
december at the latest 2023.
so that is basically the plan b the
second option if things drag out much
longer
now there is also a plan c
now this seems from what i'm being told
to be not a popular option but it's
something that kicking around as a
possibility
and that is bringing in the roland
emmerich and the endeavour and
potentially to create the original
trilogy they planned all the way back
when they produced the first stargate
movie
that would be a hard reboot all of these
other ideas we're talking about would be
soft reboots new characters but the
original stargate still exists
in this option
it would be completely wiping out
everything that's come before like sg-1
never happened
they would remake the original stargate
film
there was talk about just doing a sequel
for the original stargate movie and
maybe even james spader and curtis
rorschall coming back for that but
apparently conversations have gone on
that ronald rick believes actually too
much time has gone by and that just
won't work
so instead they want to completely
remake the original and then make the
second and third films that they planned
all those years ago
now if this happens it's going to
basically wipe out everything that
happened before but it is not a popular
option apparently amazon executive have
raised the concern that this will
annoy fans and one of the big things
that they want to do is keep fans on
side
they want to use stargate as a way to
excite interest in the mgm sale because
amazon know they're not exactly seen as
the good guys in this that their
public persona maybe isn't of a friendly
warm company and people see them quite
negatively
so they want to use this as a really a
push to get people excited and get
people on board with the amazon mgm sale
and with amazon as a whole now it seems
to be that they have had meetings with
roland emerick this has been discussed
but it's not really a preferred option
like i say
my only concern is if moonfall is a bit
of a surprise hit roland emerick's next
big sci-fi movie
then
executives might reconsider that option
they might see pound signs
but i honestly don't think this is a
threat i think it is just something
while they're in sort of a holding
pattern they've considered and they've
talked about
but i don't really think it's anything
that's going to happen the other two
options are by far the preferred ones
with plan a and plan b as well there is
really a big push from amazon they want
to do sort of like a marvel style phases
that the movies tv series games and
other projects that if this is
successful they want to bring online
will all sort of mingle together and
you'll have bad guys that appear in the
movie the tv series etc across all the
things in phases like marvel so we might
have a phase of three or four years
building up towards something quite big
that will then
influence all of the projects at the
same time and then after that move on to
something else now imagine initially
that would be something like a gold bad
guy or something along those lines or
the lucian alliance
it will build up to some a big dramatic
finale
probably in a movie and then move on to
something new after that so what do i
think will happen
i think planet is by far the option i
prefer i'd love brad right to stay
involved um and like i said there is
another development that is very
interesting that i'll talk about in
another video
i'd love there to be a big movie to
really kick start this off in a really
big bang way
i don't mind if it's a tv series then if
that's successful follow up with a movie
or another series i love the idea of
this phased idea as well of building up
to some big finale and then moving on to
something else in a sorry a marvelous
style
i don't like the plan c i don't like
this option of a hard reboot but i i can
understand why it would be considered at
very least because in lots of
storytelling ways it's much easier
but i completely agree with the amazon
and mgm people that i've spoken to and
that they are really at risk of
alienating the audience if they do that
so please get in the comments tell me
what do you think what do you think is
going to happen if this deal goes
through in the next few months
i think we're going to get something
announced really quickly but what would
you like to see
please if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit that bell
notification also you can join the
channel and for a small fee every month
help me produce more content
also you can go and join us on facebook
or i'm always dumping silly little memes
and things and we can try to have
conversations there as well most
importantly though as always please stay
safe and i'll see you really soon
wow